I have a lot of diverse experiences.
that the word diversity is becoming kind of a buzzword that is negative
kind of volunteer position on something
I have lived in rural, and urban areas.
you know I have a lot of constituencies
and I realized like diversity is entering
I've gone to public school.
why do we not want people with diverse backgrounds in leadership? It’s crazy.
I grew up poor,
so these are all the things I'm thinking about when I write
I used the word diversity because if you follow me
I speak Spanish
I'm biracial, I'm Jewish,
I'm a person with a diverse background.
and sort of your case for being this position
and you had to write an essay about your qualifications
and just as a matter of course I included that
and it strikes me as so crazy,
I'm a lawyer,
I come from a diverse background.
I've lived abroad,
I've gone to private school.
I had a situation recently where I was applying for a